señor delgado bienvenido a france 24
explíquenos cuál es la importancia de la
presidencia del congreso en honduras y
por qué la división alrededor de este
nombramiento
muy buenas muy buenas tardes
definitivamente que la presidencia del
congreso nacional es muy importante se
trata del poder legislativo en honduras
el organismo que elabora las leyes y el
organismo uno de los tres organismos que
rigen entonces los destinos de una
nación a la par del poder ejecutivo y al
para la parte del poder judicial lo que
ha acontecido en el congreso nacional
inició con una rebelión interna
por parte de un sector del partido
gobernante sin embargo está esta
traición como se le ha llamado de un
grupo de diputados afines al partido
gobernante al partido ganador y que a
partir de mañana
rigen los destinos del país y se aliaron
precisamente con el sector que fue
castigado en las elecciones pasadas de
noviembre así que entonces esta traición
o rebelión como le queramos llamar
desconociendo los acuerdos de la alianza
triunfadora tiene además algunos
elementos
muy peligroso para la democratización
del país porque se está engañando
entonces con los sectores que han sido
castigados por el veredicto de la gente
y muchos de ellos vinculados a asuntos
del lavado de activos de corrupción y
del narcotráfico y esta crisis política
que se vive en el congreso cómo afecta a
xiomara castro
bueno en el congreso nacional en
honduras tradicionalmente va en
consonancia acompañando las decisiones
del que ejerce el poder ejecutivo el
presidente de la república en el caso
que tube y que se mantuviera esa
división interna pues quedaría en
veremos todas las reformas que ha
prometido la alianza democrática que
ganó en las elecciones pasadas en
noviembre pasado es decir todo aquello
que se prometió respecto al combate a la
corrupción el regreso de una misión
internacional de combate a la corrupción
y a la impunidad y la derogación de un
código penal que alivia las penas a
todos aquellos involucrados en lavado de
activos y en asuntos de corrupción todo
eso se va al traste